great so um it is my
great pleasure to introduce jennifer
chase
jennifer is now associate provost for
the division of data science and
information and dean of the school of
information at uc berkeley
before joining berkeley jennifer has
been i should say the legendary
co-founder and leader of multiple
inter interdisciplinary labs of
microsoft research
including a tiny lab in israel um
jennifer is very decorated with many
awards
for both leadership and scientific
contributions so i should say jennifer
is um is the scientist and the leader
and the
and and as a lot of vision so maybe i'll
stick to the convention of this workshop
and just skip
all the awards um so when i asked
jennifer to give a keynote talk in this
event she replied with what i should
have guessed you would say
uh let's talk and then the following day
we are having a zoom conversation with
which starts with with my very modest
request to jennifer to talk about some
of her work on algorithmic fairness
and within minutes it ends with a topic
that goes way beyond algorithmic
fairness and features an amazingly
multi-disciplinary panel of leading
figures in social sciences computer
science social welfare sociology public
health and medicine
so jennifer the floor is yours thank you
thank you so much um i'm gonna
talk for a few minutes and then i'm
gonna introduce my
my panel to you and we'll get started
with the panel
uh so um so as michael said
you know at first when i was invited to
this a while ago and it was supposed to
be a full week i thought okay i'll talk
about work in algorithmic fairness bias
in bios
things like that many
of the computer scientists here have
visited
my labs that i had at microsoft for many
years
where we had just an incredible group
in fairness accountability transparency
and ethics
who worked closely with uh with many of
the scholars here
but you know when i decided to cut why
did i decide to come to berkeley
okay and leave those wonderful labs i
decided to come to berkeley because
um i wanted to go
beyond uh the scholarly pursuits
it sounds strange to say microsoft has
scholarly pursuits
you know but but really a lot of what we
were doing were
scholarly pursuits it was wonderful
because we had reality
coming towards us all the time um in
in terms of the online world but i
the opportunities here are so great and
there are
amazing scholars in
not only computer science but also
lawn how it interacts with technology
like deirdre mulligan and pam samuelson
and others who were here
but when i got here i realized there was
even more
than that that we should be
thinking about and um i started talking
before covid times so before
covid and black lives matters with linda
burton who's one of our panelists
and you know and i and i wondered what
can we
do to get from
a lot of the questions we're
thinking about in algorithmic fairness
to really um having a social impact
and that also meant
working with the practitioners the
people
on the ground who are
dealing with the
lack of a just world
with with the inequities
so um you know
berkeley is just so rich in this area
we have a graduate school of education
that you know is trained over a thousand
k-12 teachers who deal with the reality
of that system um linda
is the dean of the school of social
welfare
we train lots of the social workers
in this state who deal with
you know everything that is
missing in our social welfare system and
the fallout
of the fallout of the inequities
we also have a school of public health
here which
um which trains our public health
workers
and you know um there there had been
last fall a paper that ziad obermeyer
who's one of our panelists had done with
send deal
uh uh sendio mulanethian and oh my i've
forgotten his name now but one of john
kleinberg's students
on racial disparities
in healthcare and that came out sometime
in the fall
it was featured in the new york times
and then
we all saw those inequities
play out in the way
kovid disproportionately affected
uh certain racial groups and economic
groups
and so what i really want to do i feel
like we are
bringing together um
the the people from these fields and the
people who
are training the folks in these fields
who can help us to understand better
what the real problems are so not have
as i said to um to ready it yesterday
these drive-by
collaborations but you know really
um really immerse ourselves but this is
very much a work in progress we are just
starting this and so i
would love to have many of you join us
in this now i will tell you about the
members of my panel
um the first is ready to baby
who um many of you heard this morning
uh her talk so beautifully set this up i
thought she was going to talk about
something more specific in her fairness
work
and she really set up
the reason why we are trying to
to do this so she's a computer scientist
in ai
and algorithms and social justice and
machine learning for
for social good she's a junior fellow at
harvard
um and i am thrilled that a year from
now she will be joining us
as a faculty member in eeks and as one
of the leaders in helping to build this
new area here uh okay
next so ready just say hi so that people
always see your face if you're not on hi
again
okay the next is linda burton
um linda is the dean of the school of
social welfare
uh she just joined berkeley a year ago
from
duke she is a professor of sociology
and she specializes in family structure
and poverty and inequality and in child
development
next so say hi linda so that you're good
morning everyone
okay next is john easton
john is joining us from university of
wisconsin
in madison where he is an associate
professor of sociology
and the director of the university of
wisconsin
justice lab before john
was a scholar he was a community
organizer
he organized for state senator barack
obama
way back when so john has gone from
being a practitioner
to being a scholar his work focuses on
criminal justice
more broadly on uh
community health and race and punishment
and the rural urban divide so
john why don't you say hi
the space bar is supposed to let you
temporarily unmute it didn't work for me
hello hi next
is marzia rasami um
marzia is jointly
she's uh uh she's a junior faculty
member
um an assistant professor jointly
in computer science and medicine at
university of toronto she does
machine learning and computational
medicine
she holds both a canada research chair
and a cfar ai chair
and in addition to doing
you know healthcare nlp
for medical records she also looks at
inequality in health care
and she's actually really pushing me
we are oh yes one other thing we're
doing which is very exciting is we are
building a joint school
with ucsf on
machine learning and ai for clinical
care
and uh marzia is is pushing me i am on
a lot of uc uc wide committees i'm
on the committee the steering committee
for governance over health care data
and marzia is pushing me to try to open
up that data so that we can discover
um you know what what is missing
in our healthcare and then finally
we have ziad obermeyer
ziad is an associate
professor in the berkeley school of
public
health he is actually a medical doctor
an emergency room
doctor um although
for the last several years he on the
side
trained himself in machine learning
and he has been he's he's one of the
leaders
in uh uh machine learning for
health care and i had mentioned his
article from last fall
which um in a sense uh
in a sense predicted what would happen
in a pandemic i mean that wasn't the
intent of it but
it just played out as a perfect
prediction
of what he had found
so those are my panelists um what i
would like to do
is i'd like to
get to know each of them a little better
so i would like each of them to spend
you know a few minutes five minutes
telling us a little bit about themselves
their background and their work and why
they
think it is important to build a
community of scholars and practitioners
together
as we consider
um fairness and social justice
so uh in alphabetical order let's start
with readyit although she we we
heard a lot this morning from her but
maybe just a few more minutes and then
we'll move on
to linda sounds great
um thank you jennifer and thank you
everyone for
sticking around for this panel i think
we started a lot of interesting
discussions earlier this morning and i'm
happy that we'll have an opportunity to
continue some of those threads so you
you saw a bit about my research
this morning so i won't repeat it but
i'll say that
you know i work on a mix of uh
theoretical
uh theoretical applications and also
sort of
on the ai side as well sort of
applications of machine learning
but more than that what i'm really
focused on is
um is helping in issues related to
poverty and inequality right so
really i try to work on problems where i
start with the problem and then i see
what techniques that i might need and
that's led me to do
sometimes very theoretical stuff and
sometimes very applied stuff and i sort
of just
work my way backwards and i think that
that's actually
something that we as a community could
do more of
i think a lot of times we um we have our
set of techniques or tools that we
really like
and we sort of develop them and we maybe
use language that makes it seem like
the work could be applicable but then in
reality when we go out there
it's actually like it's not quite the
right fit right so it's a sort of like
you know you have your hammer and you're
looking for a nail
sort of analogy and i think we really
need to flip that on its head and think
about
what it would look like if we were to
start with a domain
really try to understand that domain uh
know the people in that domain build
relationships build trust
and i appreciate what martha said this
morning about actually coming in with
humility
about you know whether you're actually
needed at all it might be the case that
uh that you're not and and then having
that guide the kind of research that we
want to do so i think that
uh is something that's incredibly
important that i hope we'll get to
talk more about um so with that i'll
stop because i got a chance to speak a
lot this morning
and i'm excited to see how this
conversation evolves
okay so next my
partner in crime linda we are we are
building the theme of human welfare and
social justice at
berkeley in our new division which by
the way wanted to tell you it's no
longer called data science and
information
it is computing data science and society
that is the official name of the new
division
okay linda good morning everyone and
as i begin my comments i want to send
out a special thank you
to jennifer for her collegial spirit
her just willingness and mission
to mentor others and to bring others
along and
most importantly for your friendship
jennifer uh
you are amazing and i'm really happy to
know you
and to be able to work with you
so it's
we are truly partners in crime and we
are going to do
amazing things i just know that um
so as jennifer indicated to you i am the
new dean
of the school of social welfare at
berkeley and
i i come here as the new dean
as i'm a sociologist by training which
is
often an unusual uh
discipline to uh in terms of leading
a school of social welfare so what that
means
is i have the bird's eye view on
in my position as dean and as a
sociologist
on practice so i get a chance to see
what's going
on on the ground with uh individual
individuals in the communities that we
serve as well as the training
of our students to be able to do that
but in addition to that i bring the
the scholarship along with it as well
and scholarship about social
relationships
i'm very theoretically oriented and
i love all kinds of methodological uh
perspectives
uh in fact i'm what you might call a
a big scientist type of uh
sociologist and what that means is
i i really thrive on opportunities to do
collaborative research to do
interdisciplinary research
i've been involved in some of the
largest studies for example
of welfare reform and its impact on
families using mixed methods approaches
one of the largest studies in the
country
on that so that's important to keep in
mind as
we move forward in our initiatives here
but methodologically i would have to
describe myself
as an ethnographer and what that means
is i
study context and um
i look at change and over time in
in individuals and social relationships
um in institutions i look at those
things
over time because i'm not uh studying
families that say i go to visit them one
day and that's it
uh the longest time i've ever been
engaged in studying
uh families on particular studies that
i've worked in is seven
years so i get to learn seven years
intently
of those individuals lives and in doing
so i pay considerable attention to what
people say
and how that might like look different
for what they
actually do so i'm very curious
to see what comes out in our
collaborations
in terms of how we're able to capture
that
but the consistency between what people
say and what they
actually do because we all know that
oftentimes the devil is truly in the
details
when we look at these particular issues
and that nuances
are extremely extremely important
as we think uh about understanding
uh not only you you uh human behavior
but the behavior of
institutions as well what are those
nuances
that we might not necessarily be able to
capture
with surveys or certain types of data
but
may have really critical explanatory
value in terms of us understanding
outcomes
so uh i know one of the first questions
dinner proposed to
uh us and i'll i'll say deal with this
very very quickly
i wanted to say that in building
collaborations we all have to understand
that we
bring very sometimes very
different currencies to the table but
that
all of our currencies have value
and as i look at the currency that we as
individuals in social welfare and
sociology bring to the table
we currently right now bring a currency
that is extremely important in
the world order and how we move through
that and that
is the social social consciousness
that we bring on the ground about issues
of
social justice and and
and fairness and specifically right now
as
we deal with those issues around race
um in addition to that i'll just uh
end with saying as we move forward in
collaboration
some other uh points that i think are
important for us to consider that you
probably have
already covered in the conference is our
language
and how we understand the language of
our disciplines and how we relay that to
each other and explain it to
each other so that we're able to
communicate effectively
around the issues that are most
important to us
um the framing of the work that we do
what is the theoretical
uh approaches that we use in the and the
work that we do
and how do we use the inductive and
deductive will how do we
wheel how do we go back and forth uh
asking questions addressing questions
both inductively and deductively to come
at
new perspectives and addressing the
issues
it's also important that we don't see
each other as
add-ons to any project that we're all
in and in in real time and very
dedicated
uh to our projects right at the
beginning
that none of us are add-ons uh that
we are also are inclusive
and uh including the communities
that we work in members of the community
uh in our the work that is done so that
they
only not uh help or actually
develop some of the questions research
questions that are
actually addressed but that their
feedback on whatever answers come
from those questions are also
incorporated
in the interpretation and finally
that we also look at multiple levels
simultaneously
i have always been intrigued by
the work that allows us to look at
individuals
social relationships contexts
institutions and public policies
simultaneously
to give us a better sense of how those
factors might interact
with respect to uh shaping
uh outcomes that are important for the
betterment of mankind so i'll stop right
there and thank you so much
thank i'm here jennifer can you guys
hear me
okay um i want to first thank jennifer
for the uh
for being invited here um i also want to
acknowledge linda burton who was
uh my postdoc mentor duke who
um gave my uh research trajectory a
whole different
uh bend from uh the moment i met her
forward uh i was able to figure out uh
a very a very difficult discipline
to navigate um so i want to
acknowledge and thank both jennifer and
linda um
linda actually covered several of the
topics i was going to
hit on so i'm going to give a little
more personal
account of uh who i am and
what why uh my experience is important
for understanding algorithms um
we all know that uh six and ten uh
six and ten americans either know
someone or has a family member
incarcerated or has a or someone who's
been incarcerated
for african americans is nine out of ten
long before these reports were produced
i grew up black in america so i i
understood this and this is actually
what drove my research agenda
and drove me to be a community organizer
actually
started organizing on the south side of
chicago at the age of 22
hoping to reform housing and a criminal
justice system
what i found was that uh at that period
it was difficult to go beyond what was
just on the ground
so i began asking questions in terms of
the small
research actions we were doing that led
me into grad school
about why we were producing so many
people
partly why we were sending so many
people to prison
and the answer was simple most people
said oh it's an economic
answer it's about jobs and in fact i
start my book
big house on the prairie rise of the
rural ghetto uh
and prison proliferation uh with
a community action um and a reflection
on uh some of the work we were doing
at that time where we were closing drug
houses on the south side of chicago
and uh at the end of one of these uh
marches where we had a police commander
agree to
shut down one of the drug houses this
was about our fifth
at the time um a
a older gentleman stated that we were
simply sending
our black children from our
neighborhoods
down state in illinois for white workers
to get
jobs um this is what inspired me to go
back to school um to figure this puzzle
out
was just in fact true and i i
began collecting data uh on every prison
ever constructed in the u.s i now have
the largest
and most complete data set uh through
the prison proliferation project
where i know where every prison is and
when it opened
uh all seven all 1663 facilities
i got so interested in this that i took
my wife
and two small children to rural arkansas
to study the place called forest city
and
reconstruct their social history as to
why they built the prison
now what does any of this have to do
with big data you'd ask
well i'm a multi-method researcher and
the what some people may call me search
uh that's researching yourself in a way
or using
qualitative methods which seem less
rigorous
and more slippery and less accurate i
actually argued uh it allows you to be
more
reflective reflexive i should say it
allows you to be more reflexive
and actually interrogate data in a way
that you might not uh using other
methods
i in fact use uh reflexivity and
quantitative analysis so um
i think there's a lot that uh we can all
learn from each other
there's a debate right now in the
criminal justice field
uh there's a recall uh on algorithms
themselves uh
as part of the call to defund the police
so i'm gonna save my comments on that
for when we get into those
questions thank you
thank you so much john uh
marzia hi everyone uh that's a hard act
follow so the reason that i
got interested in health as a machine
learning person
uh is actually because i was talking to
my
doctor friends in boston and they were
telling me uh you know stories about
being in
clinical situations and not knowing what
to do and
i thought well don't you you know don't
you have evidence don't you have
guidelines that you can sort of leverage
in these situations
and they gave me a lot of clinical
literature
that i was not aware of at the time
being a computer scientist
demonstrating that there often is not
very much evidence
on what makes sense for all patients in
given situations randomized controlled
trials are very spotty
and then even worse as i discovered
later on in my phd
often randomized controlled trials are
very biased and so the evidence that we
have
about how to treat people is based on
populations that are
convenient to recruit or that the
recruiter
feels are most representative of
humanity
so young white college educated men
so this is problematic because when we
talk about
the uh you know machine learning
revolution and healthcare
there's sort of this assumption that
medicine is a science
this is an objective field of study we
have ways that we treat people
there are known effects and causes that
we can leverage
and maybe it's like computer vision
maybe if we have enough pictures
and we show enough dogs we could have
people label these dogs and then we
could have an algorithm learned to
detect dogs
but that's not the situation that we're
in the setting is very different
here we have images case reports
examples ehr data all of these things
very heterogeneous
that sometimes have bias embedded from
the get-go
everything from what questions are
funded to be studied in clinical
medicine
there's very little done on
endometriosis
it affects one portion of the population
going further to once you're studying a
problem
what kind of graduate students are hired
to study that problem
what kind of papers get published what
kind of people
can participate in your clinical
research studies
so whether we're talking about
retrospective data analysis for health
care
or prospective data collection in
clinical trials
bias is baked in because doctors
researchers scientists are humans and
humans are biased
there's so much bias in this system i do
think that there's a huge opportunity
for people in machine learning to
actively engage in the domain
understand how deeply rooted biases
in medicine and how specifically in
north america it has been deployed
against indigenous communities and
people of color historically
there are horrible examples that are in
every textbook and many that are not
recorded in textbooks
i think that we can potentially not make
things worse
but one of the things that i believe
very strongly is if people who do
machine learning don't engage very
deeply in the domain in healthcare we
will make things much worse
so it's not a given that all of this
automation
optimization prediction counter factual
estimation
is not going to make things worse for
very specific portions of the population
uh so i the last thing i want to say is
this was really driven home to me by
a student who still comes to every talk
i give
and asks the same question she she comes
to every single talk here in toronto
and at the end she says can you give me
one example
of when it is to my advantage to report
my gender and my race she's a black
woman
to an algorithm where i will get
something better in a tell give me an
example in finance and education and
health care
i have yet to come up with an example of
when
her providing her race and her gender
to an algorithm would benefit her and
until
we can answer those questions i think
there's a lot of
conversation and soul searching and
really deep
embedding in the domain that has to
happen with people who work in
machine learning algorithmic fairness
and in these domains
thank you mauricio so finally
we turn to zeod who as i said is
actually a doctor
and a machine learning
researcher and in this stunning article
i feel predicted what we saw with covet
thanks jennifer i think that's uh far
too kind to the work
um but but i will say um i wanted to
just
share one tidbit uh with you guys from
this article because i think it um
i think it illustrates that the kind of
research that i i
do and that i think is really important
to do um the
the the basic um point of the article is
that
uh we were studying an algorithm that
was used to
allocate an extra help program to people
who needed it so the
the algorithm was trying to find people
who needed help with their health
and to find people who had big health
needs
they did something that actually sounds
very reasonable which is they
found people who had large health costs
and the reason that that sounds
reasonable is because in general
when you're sick you go to the hospital
and you generate costs
and in general the more costs you
generate the sicker you are
the problem is that when you're black in
america or when you're poor
in america or anywhere you don't get the
same level of access
to the health care system when you need
it and so even though
on average sick people cost money
on average sick black people cost less
money
than sick white people and
and that has its roots in a number of
structural factors about our society and
our healthcare system that has its roots
in the fact that doctors treat people
differently
because of the color of their skin but
whatever it is it
translates into this um fact that
conditional on health black patients
have lower costs and an algorithm that
simply predicts
costs is going to build in that
structural disadvantage
that black patients face so
why do i bring up that um fact well
i think it illustrates a certain kind of
problem
that's really really important for us to
solve that we see in
lots of different fields from criminal
justice to uh
hiring and labor economics to to health
and so the problem that we were studying
was on one hand a
very technical problem about measurement
error like the difference between a
proxy variable that we have and a latent
variable that we care about
it's about covariance structures between
health and cost and rate
so you know it has many technical
features
but on the other hand it's about a deep
question
which is how do we measure health what
is health
how to race and poverty condition our
access to care
um and and so how we formulate a problem
and i think i saw uh
salon was was here somewhere although i
don't see him on my
big gallery of zoom people he's
described it
as how we formulate a problem and that
is fundamentally a multi-disciplinary
rich
thing that requires both of those skill
sets
and so you know i i have a lot of
collaborations with people that i've
learned a lot from
and i think when people think about
interdisciplinary collaborations like
you know if one of you wanted to
collaborate with me i think like
you know the dominant way we think about
these is like okay well i'm i'm the
doctor on the project and i contribute
some
you know substantive knowledge and then
someone else does the math
um and and i actually think that that's
fundamentally the wrong way to think
about these problems
um and the proof of that is that you
know
we stumbled on this large-scale bias in
an algorithm
that was being used to make decisions
for like tens or possibly hundreds of
millions of people
in the u.s alone the data scientists
that developed that algorithm did not
catch it
the doctors and public health public
policy people who bought the algorithm
didn't catch the problem
the doctors who applied the algorithm to
their patients didn't catch it the
patients didn't catch it themselves
so you can't just rely on like engaging
people to solve these kinds of problems
this requires
enormous investment on both sides so
that means that you know um uh when you
look at like marzia's work which is you
know
some work that i know well marzia has
made enormous investments in learning
about health
i have made enormous investments
learning about
math and as most of you know doctors are
generally enumerate and so like that's
despite
everything about medical education that
kind of tries to beat the math out of
you
um but but it's a huge investment on on
both sides
um and so i i wanted to bring that up
because i think that
that's i think fundamentally what is um
wonderful about the work that
is going on at berkeley the the
collaborations that i've been involved
in
outside of berkeley as well and i think
what it means is that you know when we
think about how we diagnose and fix
problems and algorithms you know our
work suggests that
the difference between um a good
algorithm
that you know is fundamentally
progressive and reallocates resources to
people who need them
and a bad algorithm that is regressive
and and
gives more to the people who have more
already is a series of very small
technical choices that really really
matter
and you can't see those and you can't
make those choices correctly
unless you really really know both the
content area
and also some of these technical skills
along with it
thank you then i this um
this causes me to mention one thing that
is very exciting about our new division
of computing data science and society
which is something called the data
science commons which
is going to be a multi-disciplinary
home for scholars so everybody you see
here it has a certain amount of risk
tolerance
the the five people who spoke here have
some risk
tolerance in that they decided to make
choices
in their careers that um
were not the fastest route to success
they're successful anyway because
they're awesome
but you know you tend to follow the
straight and narrow and especially you
know
pre-tenure people really often
you know they're they're advised to
follow the straight and narrow
because you know you want to get tenure
in one department you have to
talk to the people in that field you
have to publish in the appropriate
venues for that field
and then when we
go to hire people also there are a lot
of people with a background
in computing who unless they are
advancing the state-of-the-art in
computing will not necessarily get a job
at a top three department in computing
and i'm sure the same is true in other
fields i mean if you're
a sociologist and you're spending all
your time doing machine learning
they probably wouldn't like that either
and
so what what we are doing is we
are creating groups within this data
science
commons we are trying to define what it
means to be a deep multi-disciplinary
scholar
and to use that definition
and to de-risk so that if
someone hasn't published exclusively in
a particular field
we are recognizing them for having
impact right now we have an educational
system which
discourages impactful work of this sort
at least among junior scholars and
uh and so i think it's really important
that we give people like ziad
time to learn the math and the machine
learning and people like marzia
time to learn the the
um the medicine and people like
john time to you know
to to really um learn these
these different disciplines both the
kind of anthropological and
the more quantitative and ready it to
venture out into more
what might be viewed as philosophical
questions
rather than you know i mean thank
goodness for starting
at a few computer science conferences
that that allow this
but um but i think that it's very very
important
um now i don't know i i had
you know a few other questions i was
going to ask i
i get the impression that john was going
to
um answer a question about algorithms so
maybe we let him
do that now about you know what what we
should be thinking about as we
um as we uh create
algorithms and what we as you know
people who write
algorithms should should be thinking
about and then maybe we'll just
open it up because i think we have some
amazing panelists here
so john answer answer the
the question you they give give us the
answer you were postponing and then so
we'll open it up
the answer i was postponing was simply
that
people live in your error term there are
people that actually live there and you
need to consider
them in the context in which they live
so
we talk about a criminal justice system
for example as if it's one
thing and it's actually not just the 50
states each have a
system um there are 3 100 counties more
than 3 100 counties and more than 26
thousand u.s census places
so that goes to the multi-level nature
of any analysis you do and that's on a
national scale
right um and so i i consider context the
same way linda does
um but i'd do it at a different you at
different units of analysis that's why i
didn't want to repeat a lot of what she
was saying
but there are people in your error term
and you have to consider them and i
think being reflexive
which means uh not announcing your bias
to the world but working through your
own sets of biases
and then learning to mitigate them for
example
um if i can go on for one more minute
uh i thought i thought that most like
like many of you probably still do i
thought that most prisons were private
they were built in uh poor rural white
communities
and actually most prisons are public
uh that most prisons are run by states
82 percent of them are run by states
and as you increase the percent black
and latinx in a rural community
the probability of getting a prison
increases
if i wasn't open to uh admitting
these biases i had i wouldn't have been
able to find the counter factuals
uh which sort of set my research agenda
down a whole different path
and if we aren't willing to be reflexive
and say hey this is what i actually
think
um and then say hey i was wrong and
learn from that i don't think we're
going to be able to push forward much
thank you john so i was going to ask
more questions but
you know we only have about 15 more
minutes
um i wonder if there are
questions or comments i mean someone can
just
write comment or question in the chat
and uh and then i'll i'll call on you if
you
if you want to do it that way if not we
we have more questions um
ourselves so
no questions or comments i can also just
jump in i wanted to ask yes please do
please let me just jump in yeah
so i i think you know i appreciate um
everything that's been said on this
panel there's so much actually that i
want to respond to
but i'll just have to follow up with you
one-on-one but one thing that i really
i really think we have to talk about
this is the issues of representation
right so
going back to what you said ziad about
um
how you needed to be trained both as a
sort of as a doctor and as a machine
learning researcher
to see these issues you know sometimes
i see those types of papers and i'm like
yeah of course that happened you know
like so when we saw like the amazon
resume screening that was like oh we
removed people's gender
and so we removed their name so it's
totally fine
and and i was just like no it's not fine
clearly you did not have a woman in that
room or a woman who was empowered enough
to speak because we would be able to see
immediately all the other ways in which
our gender would show through
in our in our resumes and i think what
you're saying ziad about
um about your work which i think is
incredibly important
um and you were saying you know you had
to have had this like medical training
and machine learning training
to see that issue i think it would have
also sufficed if you had machine
learning training and you were a black
person right
if i was um dealing with one of these
algorithms and i was told this is how
we're gonna predict stuff
i would just be like um i are you aware
of structural racism like this is
clearly gonna be an issue right
and so i think there's this tendency
where
like we're starting to value
multidisciplinary collaborations we have
a long way to go but we're starting to
value them i think that's really
wonderful
but i think we don't see people's lived
experiences
as a kind of expertise and we try to
find like these like weird work arounds
to just sort of say we don't exactly
need those communities here
if we just had the right combination of
the different disciplines then maybe
that would sort of cover it
and i don't think that kind of proxy
representation is something that we
should stand for
anymore i think we should all be working
very hard to make sure that
those that are being directly affected
are actually leading the conversations
not just being checked in on every so
often
but actually leading the conversations
comments from other panelists on this
i mean i think it's it's very important
as i look over
the berkeley faculty for example well
just you know all faculty right it's not
just
berkeley by any means ready it showed us
the statistics this morning in
computer science what was it like 23
right yes i mean 13 graduates
black graduates in 2000 in
in the year you got your degree
right and and 23
uh full professors and yeah going up
from like 2.1
to 2.9 percent on black
professors of computer sciences you go
you know from full down to associate
down down to assistant professor yes and
it's just
it's um yes
and i think that we do not i mean
there's something else that i
believe about um
you know not about being a minority of
any sort i hear
sometimes that uh i'll just personalize
it to women since that's
my experience okay in the four years i
was at princeton
no other woman got her phd in math or
physics the few who were ahead of me all
dropped out yes it was
and you know and people say oh and then
when they get
tenure you know everyone just throws all
these things of them they get all these
grants they get and
it's like no you know um
the people who got to the tenure stage
have been subject to a much
stronger process of natural selection
or unnatural selection okay and so
if you were looking at you know if
if you were comparing what the top woman
in a field like particle physics
got to the top
five to ten percent of the men which was
the appropriate ratio
you'd say yeah that's comparable so so i
think
that um there is just not enough
appreciation of
what someone who is
the only or nearly the only
has to go through to get there and
we don't sufficiently take that into
account
as as we choose which scholars we are
going to bring
into our communities i mean i'm sorry i
know i'm preaching to the choir here
probably but anyway that's
my that's my
akira goldner has a question great
kira
and then involved can you hear me
can you hear me yeah we can hear you
okay
um so my question was about uh
for ziad or anyone else about like the
level of
collaboration of doing each other you
know learning each other's disciplines
that you think is necessary for example
i had a recent collaboration um of you
know using theoretical computer science
to model and understand
health insurance markets where we
collaborated with
a dominant a domain expert in health
insurance markets
but he didn't do any math and i
do not know everything about health
insurance markets we you know had some
meetings and he
you know we talked back and forth and
learned how to talk to each other and i
learned something about health insurance
markets
and he you know we explained to him our
model and helped make sure that he
thought it was a good model
but again he didn't do any math and i am
not an expert on health
and so i guess like where in between
completely separating the process with
little discussion versus
you know the doctor doing the math do
you think is the right balance in order
to
really get at the problem and understand
the issues
i'll just go first but uh if anyone else
has
thoughts on this i i don't i don't think
it's a um
i don't think it's an easy question to
answer because i do think it'll just
be so context dependent um i'll maybe
like
give you a concrete example from from
one field that i've gotten
more exposure to um which is
if you think about the example of
behavioral economics um
you know the the thing that made that
field work was that
a bunch of economists started taking
the psychology literature very seriously
um and a bunch of psychologists also
started learning how to write down
the kind of concepts that they had been
used to expressing
in kind of words in kind of you know
things that look more like greek letters
and and so i think um you know that
that field proved to be an amazingly
successful example but i think there
are other ones like i think applied math
is another really great example of like
people taking
applied problems seriously and then
learning about their own theoretical
problems from that
so i think that you know there there's a
there's a nice feedback loop that that
can develop um but but i do think
it's um i would say that
the reason it's very costly to do
multi-disciplinary work
is because the the level of investment
is huge
it's like it's you know for me at least
it wasn't just working on a paper
it was spending years like like
doing problem sets in textbooks
by myself um it was reading a bunch of
papers and the areas that i was
interested
so it's it's very costly and i think we
wouldn't
we wouldn't want to minimize that like
we have to be realistic about that and
then as jennifer was saying
we have to create the structures that
are friendly to those kinds of big
investments because realistically i
think
i'm not saying you can't write a great
paper in a kind of standard
collaboration model
but i think if you really want to push
forward something that's fundamentally
new and different
you know this market is pretty efficient
if it were easy to do
that paper would already be have been
written and so the fact that that paper
is not written
is indicative of how much investment you
need to make to get there
invol has a question
uh right i wanted to ask what would you
advise a pre-tenure faculty
who are not at berkeley and don't enjoy
this uh open-mindedness
uh want to do multi-disciplinary work
uh you should just move to berkeley
i've just been doing it one person at a
time you know i'll do
all 70 people 61 people on
yeah i i look i think honestly
um i i think it's a it's
you know it's personal risk
tolerance i think you you know we we
have to build the structures
that de-risk it we really really do
and you know different people have
different
comfort levels with risk i mean i
dropped out of high school and lived on
the streets of new york city so
somehow you know taking a risk and maybe
not getting a job in mathematical
physics at princeton wasn't going to
kill me
you know um i i think that
you know um it is hard
i think you should look if you're
looking for jobs you should look for
environments where there are people who
are going to support you i think that
um it's very helpful to have a senior
scholar
or two out there either at your
institution or someplace else
who can support you in this and i think
you should realize it might take a
little longer
i mean zeon said he had to go and you
know do all these problem sets and
you know i just worked 24 7. you know
everybody told me i wouldn't get a job
and three and a half years out of grad
school i got seven ten year offers
because i had worked that hard because
you know but i probably killed my health
i was i was working like 22 hours a day
you know um but it's just
i think it's a matter of how
[Music]
how risk tolerant you are and there are
people who become wonderful
multidisciplinary
scholars after they get tenure and it's
a little safer and that's okay too
you know but i think this community in
fact
of as as you were talking about deep
collaborations i was looking at this
community and i think
the algorithms folks and the
and the legal scholars here and the
philosophers
have really
been talking very deeply now for a
number of years
and there are conferences that are
growing up and they have
created this field now with the journals
and everything and the
publication venues that de-risks it a
little bit
and i just hope that here we can do that
more broadly we can you know
do this in the areas of social welfare
and
public health and public education
and and that we can create
this group of scholars who look at the
world
this way starting with undergraduates we
have an amazing
data science program where i i want to
start
undergraduates thinking this way before
they know there's something they should
be scared about
when it's all new can i say something
wonderful
oh sorry oh history i'm stacey dogan i'm
from
from boston university and i just want
to i i think this is kind of a pivotal
moment
for these questions i think many
institutions are beginning to think hard
about how to solve this very problem
so bu just established a faculty of
computing and data sciences that is
trying to do exactly the same thing that
berkeley is trying to do
um and if anyone is interested in um
getting to know the people in that group
please reach out to me directly or
ron canetti who is also in this um in
this session
um and uh we are also i think someone
mentioned yesterday
we're partnering with georgetown in a
project
to put together a a white paper with
guidance on both sort of pedagogical
innovations as well as structural
innovations within
universities who are innovating in the
law and technology space
at the intersection of law and computer
science
and um again we had sort of an early
workshop
in april we were supposed to have
another conference um this summer
that will probably take place in august
but if anyone is
um either interested in sharing your
insights
with us on either pedagogy or structural
innovation or interested in hearing from
us
again please reach out to one of us and
we'd be happy to
bring you into the conversation i'm
going to say one thing and then turn it
over to linda
bob brown your president called me and
tried to get me to take that job instead
of this job
he's a good guy he thinks very broadly
and i think he's doing very cool things
there and i think azara who is your dean
is wonderful
um so come to berkeley or be
you um okay and
linda what can i say briefly as somebody
who's
who's not at rpu um
uh but somebody who went to graduate
school at mit
before there was sort of this idss that
there is now
um it if you want to engage in these
problems jennifer is right you
you need to have a higher risk threshold
but you also need to be very comfortable
with having
awkward conversations and if you have
uh high quality people at your
institution i think that they will
acknowledge that the silence is awkward
and then they will make changes uh and i
went through a set of these where i
would ask a question well why can't i
have this well why is this not a policy
why is this not standard
um the silence is awkward and then they
would come
back weeks later and there would be a
new policy or they would offer
a different project so i i think you do
have to have risk tolerance you also
have to be very comfortable making other
people uncomfortable
all of us are linda had uh linda had
something
she wanted to say here uh thank you so
much jennifer
i just wanted to add from the
perspective of someone who's really
interested and committed to to
mentorship
to remind us all on the call that we are
whole people
and with respect to being home people as
we consider
the pathways we want to take in our
careers
it's not only about the risk with
respect to the work itself
and what we do in the context of that
environment
but also what it means for other aspects
of our
aspects of our lives so how
does what you want to do fit in with
other aspects of your life let's say
family life for example
in terms of your you know you're
trajecting
how are you going to integrate those
because they're really not separate
issues
i'm going to pick on john for just a
minute and and to say one of the things
i've learned from john um
you know over the years is i really had
a chance to
watch john move to the academy
but to do so with a family uh with
two really brilliant kids one that is
particularly spunky
and a wife a partner
who is pretty amazing uh to move to
arkansas
is in to rural arkansas is not an
easy move so having that particular
support was important so
the negotiations not only going on in
the job place and this is a point that
we
always forget it also goes in on
in other aspects of your life because um
you know that has to come together in a
lot of ways to give you
the not only the intellectual space but
the emotional space
to do the labor on the job so i just
wanted to
to point that out as well yeah life is
long
life is long so you know if you're
focusing on your kids right now life is
life is long you have time to do
different things at different points
in in your life yes thank you very much
jennifer
and thank you very much to all the panel
members it was a really great panel and
we learned
a lot about uh social change and social
justice
and uh what's happening in the real
world
so thank you um
let me also thank uh many people so many
people worked very hard in order to make
this workshop happen
um so first of all the simon's institute
and shafi the director of the institute
and the great staff that helped us a lot
uh
ashley and drew and also lily from haifa
university thank you very much
i would like to thank of course to all
the speakers discussants
moderators of course the leaders of the
breakout rooms worked really hard thank
you very much
and uh thank you to to my great uh
co-organizers
and niva and especially i should say to
inval talgam coin who has been the main
engine
behind all this workshop from its
inception
it was great working together and
finally
many thanks to all the participants
thank you for all the notes and for
all the interaction it has been uh
really great
uh let's conclude with a final
um poll uh just like we did in the
first day so let me share my screen
and it will take one minute
so please just scan this barcode into
your
cell phones if i forgot someone
please i really apologize
okay can we start
let's start
so what's your main takeaway from this
workshop in a tweet mode
you get it
listen what do i do if i'm on a phone
okay
lost in translation we need structure
exciting challenges deep questions
conversation more people
technical is not enough algorithmic
design matters
teaching teaching the main is the main
challenge
okay more and more is coming
of course the limitations of each
discipline
yeah we heard a lot about representation
wow there is someone here who says uh
they need they have
uh so much to learn from lawyers
okay so let's go on to the second
question
uh what was the main challenge in this
workshop in one two
four one two three words
yeah time
language long hours
late hours
yeah we have a winner here for sure
wide range of disciplines yeah okay time
repeats also in the small ones
so if we had a classification algorithm
here
we would have had time even bigger
absolutely
okay and okay so answers are still
flying in
ah too much time okay
great and the last question
how likely is it that our april meeting
will take place in person
so now we are applying uh now casting
from hell
okay well a bit pessimistic
but uh we'll see great so
on this happy note um i would like to
conclude
thank you again to all of you for your
participation
and uh really hope to see you in april
in berkeley and thank you michal
thank you michael good